hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna try to add some logic to our game
that we were working on earlier in the
week let me go to the live chat real
quick and say hello oh wow there's a lot
in the live chat already Deb Gupta asks
if if I teach react while streaming and
if I do a new project every time now we
work on the same project usually over a
series of streams and I do try to
explain a little bit what I'm doing it's
not really a tutorial but hopefully
you'll learn a little bit about react as
as we go through the project noble
savage says hi Jesse you beautiful sob
you with a little heart emoji thank you
I appreciate that
alright let's see
I'm skipping through a lot there was
just a lot of message retracted stuff so
that was most of everything's on here
[Music]
alright and then a couple questions
about what we're gonna learn about so
yeah we're using react native web and
that's basically it's basically the same
as react native but we are our target
right instead of Android or iOS our
target is the Dom right the the web so
we're building a web app using react
native why would we want to do that
because eventually first we're going to
build a web app but then we're gonna
also make Android app and maybe an iOS
app out of this and we'll be be able to
do that with pretty much the same code
so I'm aiming for 90 plus percent of the
same code to be used everywhere all
right so here's the code but let me
start with the UI just to give a
refresher and for everybody that hasn't
seen it yet I'll show you the UI I'm
gonna start this Pomodoro timer hey when
I start this timer that means for the
next 25 minutes I'm a focus mainly on
the code and I'm not really gonna look
at the chat very often after the timer
goes up I'm gonna go back to the chat
and try to catch up on all the questions
there if you have a question just hang
in there and I'll get to it in about 25
minutes so here's our UI a basic concept
is we have our hero over here we have
our enemies over here you're given a
math problem if you get the problem
right one of the enemies disappears if
you get all the enemies to disappear you
win if you get the problem wrong a new
enemy appears right and it'll so the
logic that we want to make today is we
want to verify that the user has the
right answer or wrong answer right when
they enter something in and hit submit
and we want to generate random math
problems right we're only going to worry
about addition for now that'll be the
proof of concept our our MVP right is
just going to be addition problems right
and that will basically be level one
single-digit addition is usually where
they start children out so that that'll
be level one of our of our math game and
let's go to the code and well let's
decide what we're going to do first I'd
say the first thing I think it'd be
easier to do is let's stick with a
hard-coded math problem two plus two
and then let's try to verify a correct
answer first and then if there's a
correct answer we'll remove this if one
of these enemies if it's wrong answer
we'll add an enemy once we get that down
then we'll add in basically changing the
problem every time yeah every time
there's a submission we change the
problem okay that'll be step two so step
one is just verifying the answer okay so
our entire app right now is pretty much
just this app J s file for the purposes
of the stream it's easier to have
everything in this file right now which
starts to get too complicated
we can break some of it out but this
just kind of simplifies there's way less
clicking around in different files
because I want the font size to be big
enough for you all to see I can't really
have screens side-by-side so it does
make it harder to have multiple files
open all right so we already have our
controlled input so we know what the
inputs gonna be and it's gonna be in
state it's gonna be text now let's
change that text what we copy and paste
it in here from an example of a
controlled input but really it's going
to be a number right so let's call it
answer
it'll might eventually when it gets more
complicated it might make it a bit
easier to reason about if we say answer
this state answer okay so now the value
of this input is whatever this state
answer is and then every time the text
text is entered it changes the state of
answer right so text context change or
unchanged tax changes a state and a
change in state triggers a change in
value okay and that's that's the concept
of a controlled input in react okay so
we have that and our submit button right
now is just console logging well this a
text but really it's it's gonna be
answered but we're gonna get rid of this
console log because on submit now we're
gonna check so let's say this dot check
answer all right so now let's make check
answer oops
and we're gonna use an arrow function
here for check answer forgotten equals
there you go so we're going to use an
arrow function I definitely recommend
using arrow functions inside your your
class components because it helps to
reason about the value of this a lot
easier and you don't have to worry about
binding this somewhere else so I prefer
this sorry I prefer your arrow functions
in this case all right so when we check
the answer we're gonna say
all right so for now it's gonna be two
plus two let's see how we're gonna do
this I guess we could just say
the state answer equals to was the plus
sorry the keyboard I'm using on this
computer like for streaming is just it's
a difference so I might type things a
little off okay
and actually so like right now this is
very simple the check answer is just
gonna return true or false actually yeah
this changed a little bit
check answer returns true or false we
don't want to return that let's say all
right so we're gonna say let correct
equal so basically this is going to
return true if it's true obviously false
if it's false so if correct is true then
we'll say if correct we're gonna call
this dot remove enemy else we're gonna
call add enemy okay so we haven't
created these yet we need to though so
I'm gonna add enemy remove enemy and
then no matter what we need to after
that say this new problem so we're going
to actually me just put this outside of
it since we're gonna do no matter what
so new problem so every time we check it
answer no matter what happens we're
going to get a new problem and then
depending on the whether the answer is
right or wrong we're gonna either add or
remove an enemy hit and yeah that's
gonna run
okay all right I'm just gonna save this
just to make sure we don't have any like
syntax errors going on okay everything
looks good let me check my timer - okay
in about 15 minutes I'm gonna go back to
the chat and let's create some of these
the remove enemies add enemies
mmm I think I may want to do it like
this enemy
enemies above this of a number of
enemies so we're gonna start always
we're gonna start with three for now and
then our remove enemy and add enemy is
just gonna affect the state so we can
say remove enemy will do this set state
and we're gonna say number of enemies is
gonna be number of enemies plus oops
minus 1 sorry I almost added 1 okay for
this one we'll just do a plus sign
and we'll change this to add okay so now
we should be able to test out whether or
not this is working we're not doing
anything with the UI yet we haven't
defined this we'll probably get an error
when I try to do that so let's define
this at least whoops
new problem okay so a new problem for
now is just gonna console.log something
console.log new just to make sure it's
working okay so let's try this so let's
look at our our state's so here's why
you can't oh yeah you can see that I
wonder if I can make it bigger though
okay so you should be able to see
hopefully this number of enemies 3 and
we should see this number change so
let's try to do this so I ready to see
our answer change right let's submit all
right
see we got it wrong so now the number
enemies is 4 we got it
ah okay I think I know what's happening
we need to change this state answer to
be a number so let's check really quick
string to number and Java no it's not
what I want it I don't want a number
with coma I just want a string to a
number parse int they were persons for
now percent will work I don't think
we're gonna be dealing with decimals
since this is a very basic math game so
let's just go with parse int normally I
would recommend going to Mozilla
developer Network so that's a great
resource if you check out mdn there's so
much info on on everything and then
examples so that's usually the first
thing to come up when you look up
something like that it wasn't this time
but I I definitely recommend Mozilla
developer Network so it's developer
mozilla.org but anyway for our purposes
for parts in it takes two arguments so
the first one is whatever the string is
that you're trying to turn into an
integer and then the second one is the
the the base so like we could do like
base 16 which is like hex stuff base 2
which is binary in this case we want
base 10 which is the normal number
system that that we're using right so
let's do that we'll go back to our code
and say
parse int so our first argument is our
string and our second argument is the
base base ten might be the default I'm
not sure but it's not gonna hurt to put
ten in there it'll make it clear to
anybody that we are using base ten which
most of the time you're probably gonna
use base 10 let's save that and see if
that was the issue let's see so number
of enemies is three there we are okay so
the issue was simply that it was
comparing a string to a number and those
of course are not going to be equal all
right so even if it seemed like it was
the right answer it wasn't because
behind the scenes it was comparing two
different types and so let's let's
verify that the wrong answer still
increases yep
all right awesome so our logic works
there the next step would be to actually
add or remove enemies on the screen and
I think I'm maybe almost all right eight
minutes in about eight minutes I'm gonna
go back to the chat and and answer some
questions I can I can see there's a lot
going on in the chat so hang in there I
will get to the chat soon oh we got a
lot of viewers so hey everybody thanks
for watching so here is where we are
actually adding in the enemies so we
want to do now is add in enemies based
on the value of in state of number of
enemies so now we're gonna do we're
gonna drop into some java scripts right
so in react inside of a component that
kind of looks like HTML this is called
JSX we can do JavaScript
if we put these little curly brackets
and so we're gonna do this state number
of enemies and see how we'll do this I
guess
I was gonna do normally when I do this
I'm like going over an object so alright
this is this is not normally I'm just
like here take this bit of data that's
an array and let's map over it right but
that's not the case we just we actually
just have a number okay
at some point it might be different if
we have different types of enemies but
for now let's just say we can do
actually now I'm confused I don't think
I've ever tried to do like a loop just a
simple loop in inside of JSX alright
well let's give it a shot I don't think
you can do a for loop duh
let's check this out
actually I do when I look this up so
let's say loop and JSX
there we are how to loop inside react
let's go to stack overflow first let's
see trying to do a loop okay yeah that's
basically what we're trying to do I'll
make this bigger you can't lose use a
for loop yeah you can make an array and
pass that as an argument okay
please
all right yeah I think we're gonna
situation often math is a good answer
yeah I think we're gonna have to make an
array and then maybe map over that Oh
actually red arrow functions up all
right this looks interesting let's look
into this
all right let's try this the idea is
we're gonna use this spread operator to
basically just create an array on the
fly and then map over that I like that I
like that idea let's try that or just
copy this for now and we'll modify it as
we need it okay so in here this will
have this so I said I don't need these
curly brackets
I already have them and this is gonna be
this state number of enemies we're going
to map over that I don't know why we're
gonna have I don't really need X I just
need I and if that case I don't need
these I don't need this object row but I
would like to have this key
okay I'll explain what I just did here
okay so what I think is gonna happen
we'll see is that an array will be
created with the the number of elements
in the array will be equal to the number
of enemies then we'll map over that
we're gonna get the the index of of each
one of these and add it as a key
so in react anytime you're you're adding
the same elements to to the Dom you need
to have a key to differentiate the the
elements okay all right so let's see if
that works so you should be able to tell
right away hey cool
number of enemies now we don't actually
even need to do the math we could just
change it for nice let's see how it does
when we add a bunch whoa whoa okay so
yeah so for right now this is imperfect
because right once we get high enough up
there it it's just a wall of enemies so
we'll have to add in some logic to
handle that maybe drop into like two
rows like we'll figure that out but for
now basically you know this works right
probably the best thing to do for now
would be to place a limit like you know
they'll never be more than let's say if
with the six work yeah so like let's say
they'll never be more than six enemies
at once we won't let you get above six
and that'll be like a temporary solution
to that issue
we can add this in I guess to add
enemies this if number of enemies if
this state number of enemies is less
than 6 then we will do this yeah so
otherwise we won't so let's let's try
this out again say like so we can see I
can never get more than 6 enemies at
once
that's not bad realistically like if
there were a kid you know a young kid
learning math and he kept getting the
answer he or she kept getting answered
wrong it would be pretty discouraging if
there were a ton of enemies they'd feel
like they'd never be able to win so this
is probably a reasonable thing to do
anyway all right cool so the timer just
went off so I'm gonna set 5-minute break
here and I go back to the chat answer as
many questions as I can let me scroll up
a bit see where I left off wow there's a
lot in the chat I'll try to do as much
as I can I don't know if I'm gonna get
through it all in five minutes though
all right so education says hello bro
can we add native code in react native
project yes you can add innate it so I'm
assuming you're you're talking about
adding like native Android or iOS code
right in that case the answer is yes so
there's there definitely ways to do that
so I mean I would you know like look at
the documentation for specifically how
you would do that in Android or iOS oh
Michael says I know what proof of
concept is but what is MVP MVP is
Minimum Viable Product so sometimes
you'll hear people talk about really a
proof of concept is usually like a step
before Minimum Viable Product so your
proof of concept is just like okay like
is this idea like even doable at all
like we need something to show like
people higher up in the organization
that this actually can work and then
your Minimum Viable Product would be
what you actually launch with so there
might be like your your very first
version of the product it's supposed to
be like have minimum functionality and
the idea is that you would then add
functionality as it becomes more popular
when I seem on tuff's already set it so
thanks for that and I'm on put the link
right in there to be able to use native
code with with react native so thank you
so much you want a lot of people were
saying hi I'm just gonna wave and then
say hi to everybody because I don't want
to take up too much time since we only
have an hour
Ahmed says I want to learn programming
that's awesome
Nino says are there any free courses for
game developers I'm sure they're out
there I don't know of any good ones
myself because I don't normally really
do game development if anybody in the
chat knows of any good free courses you
know let letting you know no please
Wallace says I need a three Jas tutorial
anyone here can help me yeah I don't
know of any tutorials on three Jas off
the top of my head but if somebody does
please put that in the chat man phone
says every time I open programming
livestream the first where I hear is um
I apologize for that I noticed on the
last stream that I was saying a lot more
I think I'm out of practice and when I
used to stream pretty much every day I
don't think I was as bad and now that
I've gotten out of practice I think I'm
not communicating as well as I did
before so I'm gonna work on that I'm
gonna try it definitely takes mental
effort to stop myself from saying it
dragon hunter says I'm just getting
interested in writing a react native
game using a webview component and boom
alive Cody with Jesse Oh awesome that's
really cool that worked like that no one
savage has hit that like button so my I
do have to say this so my team at work
is I'm gonna keep the story short but
like basically they claim that they that
on one of my live streams I ended with
smash that like button fam I never
remember saying that and they've never
been able to actually show me the stream
where that happened but they always want
me to actually say it so I'm gonna say
it just one time to make them happy so
anybody watching right now smash that
like button fam all right there I said
it now it's it's official
rabbit work says make your life easier
and either do it fully native views or
just to react at building apps to run
inside a webview component is
counterproductive
yeah actually so dragon honor was
talking about doing a native game inside
a webview yeah I don't I don't think you
need the the webview yeah I would try to
do if you're gonna do react native you
know just do react native I don't worry
about the the webview if if you can do
it I mean if there's some reason why you
need the webview that's cool obviously I
don't know the details of the project
but you know I do recommend that there
are advantages to not doing the the
webview all right let me I don't have
any pens or anything right with I was
gonna write down where I left off so I
can find it later but here it is I had a
couple of pens in it and it just got
knocked over
let's see alright
Oh way to say it it's not giving me time
stamps no toggle times there we go I had
had the time since turned off okay
now I should be able to get right back
to where I left off in the chat so if I
didn't get to your question right now I
will get to it after our next Pomodoro
session all right so what do we leave
off right now we can add and remove
enemies depending on whether or not we
get the correct answer but we still only
have two plus two next step let's give a
random math problem for now the
constraints are we want it to be
single-digit addition so it's always
going to be addition and it's always
going to be something that is zero
through nine okay so that should be
pretty simple you know given those
constraints
I just noticed Nikki says loving the
beige screen green screens are overrated
it says this is a temporary office in
the corner of my basement
those are tablecloths hanging up to make
walls so everybody gets on me for my my
terrible looking office but I am I made
it bid I put a bid in on a house and I
think everything's gonna work out and
I'm gonna move and the house will have
it has a basement that has enough space
for me to build in a real office and so
hopefully it would be a little bit
better of a background I'll try to do
like soundproofing and stuff and make it
a legit office that I can do these
YouTube streams from okay let's see how
we're gonna do this let's make some of
this in-state so
I guess we can just make two values and
state and then set them to a random
number each time right
okay um one and let's just start out
with zero about two zero and let's make
random number so we're just gonna make a
function that'll give us a random number
we fried don't need a random number
function I could just do this but let's
just let's do it since we we went in we
already did this so actually I'll just
look up the syntax instead of messing it
up and then looking it up javascript
random number there we are
so math.random there's what I wanna I
knew we'd have to do math.floor get
random int that's basically what we want
right
all right cool yeah this is perfect
let's just take all of this but I'm just
gonna take this much
okay so our random number generator is
we're gonna give it a max and this is
actually good because right now we only
want like 1 through 9 but eventually we
could increase the difficulty of the
game by giving this a higher max right
so then what we can do is you know we
already have a new problem don't we we
do ok so when we go for a new problem it
could just be this set state and we'll
go 1 it's gonna be this dot random num
and we'll say max is 9 and then we'll do
the same thing
here for Val - let's make sure I get
that number right for passing three
other this pass in ten then okay all
right so this should give us when you
say new problem all right great now
let's plug in there's gonna be a couple
places we're gonna we're going to need
to plug in these values so here it's
gonna be this states it's about one this
state - and so now we'll actually know
what the the values are the problem that
comes up and then in our UI we also want
to have the correct values where do we
have that so instead of hard-coding two
plus two will do this state oops we got
to put these in in brackets here
so this states one and this states
though - all right let's shut that up it
should we should see zero zero first and
this should actually be zero wait did we
get the wrong answer for that
hold on a second zero plus zero should
equal zero right
what what the heck why did that happen
okay that one is zero about two is zero
our answer should be zero right
all right we found a bug for some reason
when the answer is zero it doesn't work
that's not gonna matter for right now we
will have to solve that eventually like
when we get to let's say I'm basically
just gonna skip it for now right let me
see if somebody oh did I misspell
something all right
so where did I misspell Maseo says I
miss tight Val one and I wrote VA one
okay let's see where did I do that BA
one all right thank you I'm glad I
looked up there
all right let's assess this out now it's
just your zero alright that works now
now I don't want the first problem to
always be zero plus zero so we're gonna
do component did mount a non component
did mount we are going to call new
problem right so now we should get a
random problem every time right so we're
gonna refresh we're in a problem random
problem great let's play through the
game and just to make sure that it works
so you know what I just noticed we
didn't add a way for the user to press
ENTER and for this to work so let's do
that
Oh a 3/4 season
I'm interested to see what'll happen now
will it go negative we got an error cool
so we definitely need to make sure we
can't go negative so let's say when we
go to check the answer if it's correct
we remove the enemy and then let's check
and say if this state number number of
enemies equals zero then we'll say let's
say display u1 I'm just going to name
the function u 1 because that sounds
cool right this this dot u 1 u 1 is
going to for now all it's going to do is
just display
the states it's gonna set States and
over this state one which will create
that value oops it's not what I want
she's gonna say one equals true and yeah
for now that's what we'll do so say one
equals true and then up here let's add
one false anytime you have anything
that's going to affect the UI at all you
probably want to keep track of it in
state because a change in state will
trigger a rerender of the component and
that's what you want to change your UI
so if that happens we're gonna want to
display let's see so instead of this
math container let's just put in one if
one is true then let's put in this let's
just say victory and then otherwise
let's display this this view right and
this obviously isn't styled yet we gotta
say this state one right all right so
let's see if that works and we can skip
the actual game and just set this right
no all right let's try it again and oh
yeah you know what it hmm one is still
false all right I think there's
something wrong with my logic here so
let me check up here
let's see so we're checking so we're
doing this don't remove enemy which
should take the state down and then
we're checking for if the state number
of enemies is equal to zero you know we
could do we would probably could move
this honestly to here anyway
okay
alright let's see now
914 for hmm still something wrong with
it
let me see shouldn't it be inside the if
let's see
okay Nikki said this head state is not
sink use updated function to guarantee
you get the latest value yeah I was
worried about that so you think the
problem then is that I'm I'm checking
state before state has had a chance to
actually update use updater function
Nikki would stop dinner function
you check my time too I've got about
nine minutes this it's the previous
state equals logic all right awesome
so Nicky let me know if I'm using this
wrong set stays like this
yep all right
see if this works I'm glad we set these
really easy math problems
be embarrassing if I couldn't figure out
the problems No all right still didn't
work actually we can just test to see
what comes up anyway all right so we did
it if we can get one to signal true then
we will get this victory to come up okay
so it doesn't look great now but at
least that that does come up and then I
evidently I did this wrong
let's see hey her shirts here after
going he says will change the number in
state first
good
okay this pre-stated we're enemies I
wouldn't sure the state is updating and
you get the right value all right let's
see
[Music]
all right let me I'm getting a lot of
advice here so let me read this so harsh
is saying the syntax is wrong you can
use callback as a second parameter this
free state number of enemies
this one sure the state is updated and
you get the right value replace that
first set state syntax is wrong use the
second parameter okay
Hey hits so many so many things here
okay so
miki-san costs
then call your logic with number doing
enemies if all right Sonique e saying I
could do Const oops
and then harsh it has went to show
Michael states start over for you number
of enemies for you even though version
of me knows huh oh I see what you're
saying with the call back now all right
let me let's
all right let's so this set state
previous number of enemies Cruz
okay so we're setting number of enemies
the previous number of enemies minus one
and then as our call back then we're
gonna do this stuff
right what the heck
unexpected character
dang it I think since I copied and
pasted it it's giving me it's messing me
up here I'd have to type this I just
said stay trees
let me see
pack is
hi
okay
you just caught me and pasted this right
now I'm gonna type it all out and say
9:32 as the air all right where's my my
error here after that first treat
numbers enemies -1 put ok
all right there we go
I spelled Expo two enemies wrong enemies
know what now it's not suggesting that
spelling to me enemies it's all right
let's uh let's walk through this for my
sake and for everybody say so so what
we're doing here is saying when we go to
remove the enemy then we're gonna call
this set state we're gonna look at the
previous state and we're going to set
the new state the new number of enemies
to the previous number of enemies minus
one then after that occurs and that's
it's in this callback right we're gonna
say if the number of enemies is why does
it say less than what the heck was I
doing
if the number of enemies equals zero
then whoa why did I just do that
no I copied the wrong stuff dang it all
right let me let me go back here for a
second that totally copied the wrong
thing all right now our add enemies here
what I wanted to do here was if the
number of enemies equals zero then I
wanna call you one okay
all right now let's try this
yeah a one victory all right
my timer definitely buzz what time is it
yeah okay so that's pretty I mean we
basically achieved what I had hoped to
achieve for this one so got a little
crazy there at the end but I'm kind of
glad we went through that because that's
some cool syntax and it's nice that that
I learned that and that we learn that
here on the strain let me commit this
all right so I'm gonna get commit with
the am flag that means we're adding in
we're gonna get add then again commit
with the message in line I'm saying it's
a new feature right and this is we add
the logic for single-digit addition I'm
gonna push that alright cool so that's
now on github at this point I'm gonna go
to the chat and try to get in as many
questions as I can I'm also gonna turn
on my work laptop just to make sure that
I don't have any meetings coming up I
don't think I have a meeting but better
safe than sorry right
okay
okay
alright I'm gonna skip through like a
lot of the discussion and and kind of
just focus on questions
okay I'm good I don't have any meetings
right now so I can get through this
okay so maor says hey how can you get
the output of a Jas on Microsoft Studio
2019 I have no idea so I've never used
Microsoft studio so sorry about that if
anybody knows the answer that question
please put it in the chat
okay Pavan says which one is good for
creating a discord bought nodejs or
Python I don't I don't really know
because I've never created a discord but
if I was going to do it I would do it no
js' because I I know no js' and I'm not
good with Python so that's just me but I
don't know what the official like but if
there is a best way to do it I don't I
don't know
like John Hanson says the Musketeers are
here for our yeah I like so for those of
you that didn't watch before there's a
couple of people for that used to watch
the live streams regularly kind of a
couple months back when I was doing
pretty pretty much every day so it's it
is really cool to have you all have your
back I kinda I missed I missed hanging
out all the time you know
all right so David put in a link to an
EDX course on game dev so when you paste
a link into the chat it's hidden
automatically I just under hit it so
y'all can check that out
see
is it true so we have a question this is
is it true if you get a certificate with
free code camp I can use it on my resume
yeah I mean you do get a certificate at
least like an electronic certificate and
yeah I would definitely put it on a
resume under like certificates or
education you know like I got a
certificate for the Udacity react nano
degree program and that that is on my
resume so I yeah I would definitely put
that on there anybody that's familiar
with free code camp will know you know
what that means
Alberto's making fun of me here so she
looks around for paper and pencil while
having a computer with no pay ah that's
so true I definitely I could have just
like I had an editor open why did I
think I needed a notepad Oh
Patrick says that background makes you
look like a hardcore hacker alright I
feel better about it now so it's that's
a good way to look at it Kersh it says
oh classes Twitter people will say it's
a crime now yes so if now that react
hooks are out they're actually not out
officially yet in react native so I
think they're gonna come out the latest
I saw was either Monday or Tuesday of
next week
they'll come out in a stable version
zero point five nine point zero but yeah
so for now I think classes are still
acceptable in react native but otherwise
everybody's saying just use hooks right
and go with your functional components
I'm gonna try to add in hooks as much as
I can but really realistically I'm so
used to classes at this point it would
it's faster for me to just use classes
John says install a disco ball there's
not enough of that effect on code
regimes at the moment you know what I'm
gonna do about once I get enough views
on my personal channel to do the like
the super chat I'll make it a thing on
the super chat they're like if you
donate $5 the like disco ball will spin
around and lights will go off or
something how about that
yes
all right John Hanson's we're just to
give you a little bit more info about
hooks John says hooks are very simple
and efficient when you realize how to
get them to work when you change a
complex class component with a lot of
state props and timing involved to a
function getting there yeah a hooks look
amazing if you don't know about hooks
look up Dan Abramoff's talk introducing
reax hooks and also what's his name
right after that talk at the same
conference someone else did a talk where
they actually demoed react hooks and I
can't remember what this guy's name was
like I actually went to an in-person
training with him and I can't remember
his name anyway but that was at what
conference was that it was like the end
end of last year maybe or something that
it was announced if anybody knows what
videos I'm talking about if you put the
link in the chat out all on hide the
link Kuby world says what vs code font
is that I do not know it's I guess it's
whatever the default font was cuz I
don't think I ever changed my font the
theme is called SETI SETI
Nietzsche says remember the prevent
default in your submit handle or the oh
yeah we can
so Nikki's idea earlier we were talking
about how I can't right now I can't hit
enter to submit so said if I just make
it a form of automatic xx of
accessibility support but I have to
remember to prevent default so it
doesn't do your normal like post back on
the forum and refresh the page that's a
really good idea I have to make sure
though would that work because like in
react native would that work if I want
to turn it into a a mobile app I often
double check on that
Matt ass says I'm just starting off with
Python there's anyone having any advice
on fun codes to learn starting off I'm
not really sure I don't do much with
Python Oh Nicky just said oh does that
work in react native so you realize that
before I did
all right I'm gonna skip a lot here
because a lot of it was just that back
and forth trying to figure out what
syntax I should use right here
dish deshmukh says please make tutorials
on react native navigation in 2019 ok
I'll think about that I am I am gonna
have to work with react native
navigation at some point like at at my
my real job so I'll think about doing a
tutorial like when I when I get into
that as well
rabbit work says cheers Jessie another
fun stream I'll be back for more good
luck thanks thanks I appreciate it
Mauri on says is the source available
online yes the source is available
online the link is in the description
michael says back in the day there only
be five or six of us yelling at at freak
ot org now there's 100 yeah this a lot
more viewers which is great we were well
over a hundred viewers at one point we
dropped down a little bit now but yeah
it's free code cam channel let's just
took off like there's so many
subscribers now
we have any channel for react beginners
I'm not sure I do have my channel does
have some react stuff on it
I don't know what channel would you'll
suggest now for react videos Oh Rose
says another great stream I have
motivation overdose Thank You mr. Jesse
oh you're welcome thanks for watching
I had somebody put uh-huh
[Music]
alright somebody did put a link in -
hold on a second let me put a link in to
this react react today in tomorrow 90
Frank linear with react hooks this is
this is the talk that I was talking
about
and unfortunately whatever yeah all
right now it's coming back I lost all
the chat for a second because I I
clicked on the link and navigated away
now it's coming back it's just gonna
take a second to load but anyway I
pasted that in there also show the the
link m40 got the link that is the one
Ryan Florence there we go the the man
who did the like demo on react hooks
where he actually took an existing
project and converted it over to using
hooks is Ryan Florence yeah then he is
the guy that made react router
Nations is can I use reacts for UI
validation only without anything Beckett
you can use react only on the front end
I'm not exactly sure if that's what
you're asking but you can do just
front-end react Tania says how many
languages do we need to make responsive
website you can make a responsive site
with just HTML and CSS if you want to do
anything more complicated though you
will need Java scripts somebody asks of
the screen is stuck no probably not I'm
just not coding right now and I may be
my face was really still make a video of
how to make a Ludo star game I don't
know what Ludo star is so I probably not
the right person to make that video
alright cool so I think I've gotten
through everything if I miss your
question I'm sorry you can put it in the
comments below the video and I'll try to
answer it later or you can wait till the
next stream and ask me or you know feel
free anybody if you have questions to
message me on any social media I'm
active on Twitter and Instagram mostly
the links to my social media stuff and
my youtube channel are down in the
description so I'll be back next week
probably be back on Wednesday I may do a
graph QL tutorial at some point this
weekend on my channel so if you're
interested in that I'm gonna be using
Apollo server to wrap an existing REST
API in in graph QL so hopefully I can
get that done this weekend if you're
interested subscribe to my channel and
then you'll be notified whenever
whenever that video comes up otherwise
have a have a great weekend thanks for
thanks for watching and in helping me
out and I'll see you next week